this guy stole 120 million dollars from
Google and Facebook and it nearly got
away with it hearing this you're
probably thinking that this guy of all
this Ramos Oscars was some sort of
insane hacker or Insider he must have
breached through Google security systems
or used Insider knowledge to Cipher
money from Facebook but in reality he
was just an ordinary man from Lithuania
and the scheme he used wasn't especially
notable either he used a classic email
phishing scheme yet somehow he was able
to trick some of these smartest people
and companies in the world the craziest
part was that these companies didn't
even know they were being scammed and he
could have easily gotten away with it if
he didn't try to push his luck you see
evaldus didn't just set out to hit a
jackpot and retire he was looking to
defraud as many companies for as much
money as possible
so every time he could link the company
he would just do it again to the same
company or the next company originally
he stole 23 million dollars from Google
throughout 2013. at that point that's
literally generational wealth but our
man of all this wasn't happy just two
years later he would Target Facebook and
debug another 98 million dollars this
greed however would eventually get him
noticed and these companies would notify
the FBI who would track him down to
Lithuania they would of course arrest
him and he would be sentenced to five
years in jail but the same could it not
be said about his associates who were
never found apparently evaldus would
wire the stolen funds all around the
world as soon as he received them
so who knows how many people were
involved and how much they were each
able to get away with but all of this
begs the question
how did he do it how was he able to
outsmart these smartest companies in the
world and to get away with it for years
and what does this mean regarding the
security of the data that all of us have
stored on these platforms well here's
the story of evaldus Remus Oscars the
guy who stole 120 million from tech
companies and it nearly got away
foreign
traces back to their early 2010s to
Lithuania like any country Lithuania is
mostly filled with awesome law-abiding
people and great culture but
unfortunately they are notorious for one
crime car theft if you've ever heard of
someone's car being stolen it was
probably dismantled within no time and
shipped off to Lithuania from there the
car parts are listed on sites like eBay
like nothing happened their listings are
usually way cheaper than everything else
on the market for well obvious reasons
but by the early 2010s authorities were
starting to catch on and they were
busting these car Rings left and right
so our Mana Valdez needed a new strategy
something that wasn't so hot and risky
something that no one was even paying
attention to one of the main problems
with carjacking for criminals is that it
basically always gets notified to the
police I mean who wouldn't report to the
police that they had their car stolen
not to mention it carjack talking wasn't
even all that lucrative given how much
risk was involved if you wanted to make
a million dollars for example and you
sold each car part for 500 on average
you would need 2 000 car parts
this means that you would have to steal
dozens of cars resulting in dozens of
police reports obviously not a very good
risk to reward ratio so avaldis decided
to hatch up his own plan he first asked
himself where can I get a lot of money
without the victim even noticing and the
answer became clear pretty quickly built
the rich tech companies there was only
one problem he was by no means the first
or the last person to think of this idea
tech companies know all about how
they're vulnerable to cyber attacks not
just to steal money but to steal
personal data top secret technology and
confidential information just think
about this even these cias stores their
information on Amazon servers so
maintaining a Secure Public Image is no
doubt a top priority for these companies
and I don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that these tech companies invest
tens of billions into cyber security but
this really only protects these
companies against cyber threats people
who are trying to directly hack into
their systems to wreak havoc evaldus
wasn't even considering this option
because well he didn't even stand a
chance against the I.T Departments of
these companies so of all this looked to
identify a weaker entry point somewhere
money was already exiting the company
this left of all this with really only
one option the payroll department for
most companies paying employees and
other businesses is by far their biggest
expense and Google and Facebook were no
exception Google for example spent 56
billion dollars on payroll last year but
paying employees is a pretty streamlined
and highly scrutinized process so this
wasn't exactly a great entry point
paying businesses however was highly
custom and it usually handled on a
case-by-case basis so if you pose as a
business you would only have to trick a
handful of people who are approving a
given invoice not the entire company's
I.T department or security
infrastructure and with that evaldez had
his entry point
foreign
companies like Google and Facebook pay
out money to thousands if not tens of
thousands of different companies for all
sorts of reasons from manufacturing and
Logistics to research and legal services
while newer Partners may get more
scrutiny when it comes to billing most
established Partners just send over
invoices and these companies approve
them without a second thought so if
Walters decided to pose as one of these
Partners a company called quanta
computer like me most of y'all have
probably never heard of this company so
here's what they do quanta is a
Taiwanese manufacturer that specializes
in producing an Enterprise Hardware like
servers they're actually super reputable
in the industry as they work with
basically every tech company you can
think of this includes Apple Dell HP
Amazon Cisco LG Sony Microsoft Facebook
and so much more so I don't think you'd
be surprised to hear that they pull in
over 40 billion dollars worth of Revenue
and 1.5 billion dollars worth of profit
every year similarly Google and Facebook
were also not surprised when they
received tab is worth a couple million
dollars from Quantum evaldus went ahead
and created fake invoices and contracts
and signed them with the names of
various leaders at quanta he would then
send over these documents to Google and
Facebook from a quanta domain email
address you know those random emails
that you get from Apple and Amazon
stating that you've been charged x
amount well this is exactly what evaldis
was doing but instead of targeting
elderly folks who didn't know better for
a few hundred bucks if all this was
targeting Tech Giants for Millions same
tactic but completely different scale
with all the articles that these
companies put out about identifying and
stopping fishing you would think that
the staff at these companies would know
better but it turns out they didn't you
see it's not like a volt discharged
Google 23 million and Facebook 98
million in one Fell Swoop according to
the Department of Justice evaldus would
regularly send a multi-million dollar
invoices to these companies if we assume
that each invoice was worth four to five
million dollars evaldus told Google 5
times and Facebook are you laughable 20
times so alright whatever people of
these companies didn't put too much
scrutiny on these invoices and they
approved them they must have some sort
of established payment system with these
companies right so even if they
accidentally made an unnecessary payment
it would be no problem getting the money
back from the real company surely these
companies weren't sending tens of
millions to some random ass Latvian bank
accounts detailed in the import they
were sending tens of millions to some
random ass latman bank accounts detailed
in the invoice to be honest I'm not
gonna defend of all this but you can't
feel too bad for these companies either
there's really no one to blame but
themselves and their gross negligence in
this situation any normal person would
have no chance of any recourse but given
the power and status of these companies
you can bet they got Justice
foreign
was smart enough to not hold on to the
money in the same account that he
received it he would instantly spread
the money across the world into bank
accounts in Latvia Cyprus Slovakia
Lithuania Hungary and Hong Kong
considering this it's surprising that he
didn't take more precautions to secure
his own Freedom especially when he's
scamming big tech companies with all
this money he could have easily moved to
a non-extraditing country like the
United Arab Emirates and lived it up in
Dubai but he would stick to Lithuania I
guess he must have felt that he was
saved behind his computer screen and as
long as the money was dispersed and
untrackable he was good this was of
course a blunder as soon as Google and
Facebook noticed some discrepancies in
their accounting they would identify the
fraudulent charges and to notify the FBI
for the FBI tracking down someone like
evaldus was relatively easy and they
would have him cornered in no time and
with the no plausible deniability if all
this would adjust plead guilty and
eventually he'd be sentenced to five
years in prison if you're wondering what
happened to the money well of all this
would forfeit to 49 million dollars of
it and he was ordered to pay 27 million
more in restitution Facebook and Google
would claim this as a victory as they
were technically able to recover the
majority of the funds at least on paper
it's not clear if of all this has paid
the restitution yet or if he ever will
so that still leaves 44 to 71 million
dollars worth of stolen funds
unaccountered for but I don't really
think Google or Facebook really cares
about recovering these funds for Google
the total stolen funds are equivalent to
three and a half hours of profit for
Facebook the total stolen funds are
equivalent to 37 hours of profit so for
these companies hatching up all this and
the pudding came behind the bars was
more about the principle and making a
statement as opposed to recovering the
funds spending even more effort on
recovering the remaining funds is really
just not worth the prettiest companies
so if all this may very well have a
fortune to return to when he eventually
gets released around the end of 2024 but
all of this still leaves the question
how was he able to pull off something so
simple against these companies well the
bright side is that while this incident
is truly quite embarrassing for these
companies it's not indicative of their
I.T or cyber security as far as we know
their systems are still as strong and
secure as ever and this incident has
little to do with anything other than
gross negligence and oversight
foreign
this story shows us that no company is
truly 100 secure I mean a random person
in Lithuania was literally able to pull
a quick one on Google and Facebook with
very little skills and resources all he
had to do was attack them when they
weren't looking he could have gotten
away with it too if he played his cards
just a little better but who's to say
that he didn't come out on top anyway
I'm sure there's a lot of people who'd
be happy to do five years in jail for 40
to 70 million dollars and the title of
successfully scamming Google and
Facebook and that's the story of the guy
who stole 120 million dollars from
Google and Facebook and it nearly got
away with it do you feel bad for Google
or Facebook comment that down below also
drop a like if you can't believe that
these companies fell for it and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest with your video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one